will get the latest on the fighting in
Ukraine with Charles Stratford in a
moment but first let's head to Moscow
Muhammad Val is tracking development
there Muhammad what has Russia been
saying about the referendum
yeah it's uh actually here in Russia
it's a Rosy picture the media talking
only about the turnout even though they
didn't give a very high figures Saturday
for instance according to Tas agency it
was between 23 and 26 but they expected
it to rise during the following days and
the same media also talking about 93
percent of those who cast their balots
in zaporizia for instance they chose to
join Russia and indonesk the authorities
there talking about
236 people have already voted and that's
a big number big number considering that
the operation so far is limited because
of security reasons phase one will end
on on the 26th and the 27th there will
be an open day of voting in a in in
polling stations as usual that's when
the biggest number is expected to turn
out and that's will be that will be the
final day the news here also news media
talking about a quick uh result being
announced quickly I mean on the
following day on the 28th the results
will be announced by the evening and uh
on the day after that the state Duma is
expected to meet and endorse those
results that's when probably on the 30th
President of Vladimir Putin will give a
speech and officially declare those four
regions officially part of the Russian
Federation okay that's Muhammad Val for
us in Moscow we're now going to go to
Charles stretford who joins us now from
cave Chelsea you've got more on the
latest fighting in the East overnight
that's right yes as those votes continue
those votes that are considered by the
International Community of the UN to be
completely illegitimate there are
reports certainly according to the
Ukrainian authorities what they describe
as heavy shelling and bombing of various
areas uh in the East and the south in
those areas that uh that are along the
contact line the ukrainians saying at
least 35 what they describe as
settlements were hit by Russian strikes
in the last 24 hours there are also
reports that we again cannot
independently verify of what ukrainians
are describing as Iranian Kamikaze drone
strikes on an administration building in
central Odessa in the South but as I say
we cannot independently verify that we
know that the ukrainians have accused
the Iranians of supplying Russia with
these drones it's something that the
Iranians have staunchly denied the
ukrainians have already
diluted if you like their relationship
with the Iranians here they've punished
the Ambassador by taking away his
accreditation
and demanding that a number of diplomats
from the Iranian Embassy leave the
Iranians are saying that they will
respond
um with some sort of proportional
response in the coming days
interestingly also there are reports on
the Russian side of con line of control
they saying that there was a hotel in
the occupied town of kerrson that the
Ukrainian military hit this morning
there are reports again that cannot be
independently verified of journalists
staying in that hotel at least two
people reported injured possibly dead so
as I say as this
a legitimate vote goes forward according
to the International Community a lot of
heavy fighting on various locations
along the contact line in the East and
the South okay Charles uh that's Charles
Stratford for us uh live from Keith
thank you
the kremlin's military mobilization has
prompted more people to flee Russia
Serbia is one of just a few countries
Russians can travel to without a Visa
Jonah Hull has this report from the
capital Belgrade
no to war they chant Russia without
Putin it isn't clear exactly who their
protest is aimed at they're Russians in
self-imposed Exile against the war in
Ukraine their presence tolerated by
staunch Kremlin allies Serbia one of
only a few countries to which Russians
can travel now visa-free
my voice might be a drop in the ocean
and maybe it won't be heard but I have
to speak out anyway Alexi novikov is
among an estimated 50 000 Russians
who've landed in Belgrade since war
broke out in February many on one-way
tickets the pace of arrivals is thought
to have escalated in recent days with
young men in particular escaping
President Vladimir Putin's partial
mobilization of reservists
I don't want to take part in a war
against the Ukrainian people for some
unclear are vague objectives and
probably very soon they will try to
mobilize and rush on mass and they will
take anyone they can catch and send them
to the front line to be used as Canon
fodder
so-called brother Nations their fellow
Orthodox Slavs in Serbia offer the
Russians familiarity and a warm
reception but given the political ties
between Belgrade and the Kremlin it's an
unlikely Harbor for Dissent it feels
that people don't understand that
Russians are against the war they really
feel that Putin and Rush is equal and I
want to express my feelings that it's
not and that we are really against the
war no one is suggesting that small
expatriate populations like this one
however vocal are about to turn public
opinion in Russia against President
Putin or the war for one thing it's
highly unlikely they'll even be seen or
heard by most Russians on state-run
media but many people here do feel that
the recently announced mobilization or
call-up of reservists is likely to bring
a new awareness of the war to Russian
homes and Russian society and that in
turn is a step closer towards a possible
Tipping Point
it is one thing to sit on a couch and
contemplate how we are conquering
Ukraine and quite another to be in a
trench with a machine gun so I think
that the dissatisfaction of the people
is already quite strong because those
citizens who support Putin and the war
have started to express their
dissatisfaction with what is happening
in Ukraine and the mobilization now will
push people to protest against it from a
place of relative safety now having left
their old lives behind these Russian
dissenters are determined to play their
part Jonah Hall Al Jazeera Belgrade
Russia has reshuffled its military
leadership naming Colonel General
Mikhail mizinsev as Deputy defense
minister he'll be responsible for
logistic operations he's under Western
sanctions for his role in the
bombardment of mariopol Kiev officials
accuse him of planning The Siege in
which thousands of civilians died as
residential buildings were destroyed
asensive has also been accused of
orchestrating the bombing campaign that
leveled much of river-held Aleppo in
Syria back in 2016.
well let's bring in Samir Puri he is a
military analyst and author of Russia's
road to war with Ukraine he joins us
from Singapore thank you very much for
being on the program and mazinsiv has
been dubbed The Butcher of Mario poll by
many ukrainians as we heard and he's
been described as a hardliner within
Russia so do you think we're going to
see an even more ruthless Russian
military now
yeah thanks very much for having me uh
these reshuffles are quite common
because Russia's War efforts has been
plagued by difficulties but your
question is is touches on a really
important subject which is are we going
to see more indiscriminate bombardments
of parts of Ukraine that Russia Is Yet
To Conquer and I think the answer is yes
and and very simply it's this at the
start of the invasion the Russian Armed
Forces try to operate with a bit more
finesse parachute drops and sort of
advanced raids into Kiev and khaki it
all failed and they reverted to type and
type is very sadly the sorts of
campaigns we've seen in in Aleppo in
Syria the Marriott port in southern
Ukraine as you mentioned Devastation of
the cityscape and Russia claiming that
as a conquest he's taking over Logistics
and supplies why do you think that's
been such a major issue for Russia's
military in this war
right well yeah amateurs talk about
strategy professionals talk about
logistics that's one of the aphorisms
that sometimes goes around discussion
about military operations and one of the
reasons that Russia's armed forces have
struggled in Ukraine comes down to
Logistics it comes down to Armed Forces
advancing without proper lines of Supply
disconnected from other lines of Advance
remember Russia invaded from from
multiple angles of Ukraine so bringing
kind of control to this chaos has been
an uphill struggle for Russia's defense
Ministry and its military command ever
since the early days of the invasion
started things started to go wrong so
indeed Mikhail Minister will be really
responsible I think for digging Russian
forces in for the Long Haul and this
then ties in with this partial
mobilization order we've also seen
happen this week and do you think this
is a direct result of the ground loss to
Ukrainian forces over the past month or
so
certainly it's it's uh part of Russia's
reorientation to this new reality in
which as you say Ukraine has been able
to retake some of its occupied land
deoccupations zelensky calls it and of
course the Russians will be alarmed that
the possibility of a Ukrainian offenses
spreading further along the front line
uh it could become something the
Russians are dealing with so I think
certainly the Russians are not on on the
front foot they're on the back foot and
stabilizing that position and playing I
think for sorry to use a sporting
analogy playing for the whistle playing
for winter which means making sure that
the Russians don't lose any more of what
they hold before winter sets in will be
one of Mikhail Minette says goals I
think we've heard U.S officials say
there is an increasingly dysfunctional
command structure in Moscow do you think
that that is the case as well
so the report of course no one can tell
you a hundred percent as to how this war
is being run but the reports that are
servicing some things in the media
suggests there is something of a sort of
a hundred kilometer screwdriver so to
speak which means a key command and
operational decisions are being taken in
Moscow whereas other Armed Forces might
delegate those to field commanders it
appears at Putin and those immediately
around him have tried to micromanage the
war from very far away perhaps often
with poor information delayed
information uh that and I think the
aforementioned point which is the
Russians invaded from a lot of different
directions at the very start and it just
meant that their military campaign was
just Mal coordinated right from the
start and they've been trying to I think
gain some coherency ever since then
Samir Puri thank you very much for your
time and your analysis